[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis vraiment
il commence à faire froid dans le ciel
alors nounours tu descends voir nicolas
et pimprenelle roues oui pas trop ça va
vous réchauffer ils m'attendent
je t'aime bien tu sais ne nous dit tu
les a bien digéré les marrons glacés
réseau de petits dons au point qui
faisait rage avec nous dit c'est pour
nous une belle ronde
la ronde du rosier petits brigands
vous me prenez par mon poids devant la
même
je commande
[Musique]
manger à quatre fleurs auront quatre
fleurs d'une charmante aux couleurs
quant à lui est arrivé paule belot rouge
quand la nuit est l'arrivée meilleur
faire condamner mais ce n'est pas fini
de quatre commissions n'ont d'autres
champignons non d'autres boutures on met
mois et les haies messieurs le bouton de
rose dans ce tous les cadres andreu un
livre merveilleux comme le sommeil élevé
le pot-aux-roses
cela alors bout du nez dans l'art osé
porter le voile et du barbouillé
pour le retour le journal
[Musique]
tu maintenant le zoo ou les
ans
mon
on
[Musique]
oh
ennui le nom de revient de très mignon
du je t'aime beaucoup vu beaucoup
d'enfants une loi aussi le plus dix ans
[Musique]
ferme ont bien les pompiers
oh
bonsoir papa maman j'ai éteint les
lumières
euros chez les petits
enfants j'ouvre la fenêtre je sens de
lui
les ensembles tête
sont endormis
je reprends monuc
je connais
au changement
[Musique]
nicolas mas prônait
le
je vous y attends
m
[Musique]
ils ont été très gentils ce soir nos
deux petits amis deux petits anges
patron deux petits anges
eh bien vous aussi les enfants soyez
aussi sage que nicolas et pimprenelle
fait un gros baiser à vos parents
allaient vite au lit et fait des rêves
d'or bonne nuit à demain à thomas bonnin
[Musique]
en
oh